that's my brother he's jews he's got
good defense and that's what uh that's
what he that's the only thing that he
told me right i'm like okay i might need
to know more about that guy and he
showed me and
and he showed me and you know what i got
convinced that's probably
that one match that i saw from him in
this one tournament
and that was an apology wow he's one
he's one of the best that was around
2019.
okay so just a couple hundred not not a
crazy amount of time
yeah that's awesome because i feel like
for sure this
obviously i feel like in this time
period right this uh this weird training
arc we have called covet online you know
a lot of players are like rising right
and the players that are focused in this
past year and a half which is almost
gonna be two years suit uh i feel like
the players that have like improved in
that time period are going to be the
players that are really the players that
are doing well going forward in the
future when we get back to offline
events it really always seems to be the
case
all right it looks like we are going to
get looks like the match here ladies and
gentlemen
we have the winners finals it is going
to be ak versus jules in the infinite
azure jewels immediately with the gen
pick i rip something i want to tell you
right now get ready for jules now if he
blocks something if he blocks a load
that's minus 13 he will crouch cancel
into switchblade i guarantee it
what
let's see it
i love i love jig players you can do it
i've seen daniel mata do that as well
[Music]
but all right the slides come out early
yeah enforcing the lows already jules
though lower than half health side step
down forward two ak can he close this
one up
perfect
yes he will
surf it out perfect ak
what a way to start off the winner's
final here
break his legs
do it again
he's going to by the way
there's no need for us to tell him
because he will he will do it all right
aka trying to go for more aggression
here the slides one after another
oh
that caught in there hold me attack
interesting choice there no sir
all the way off axis
[Music]
maybe from dreams this time
no i don't think it's going to come out
any time soon but iggy going to keep him
in check with the downpour he won the
mid
jules also try he's trying to sidestep
into hopkick but ak has such a different
timing
hey wow what a good crap that's one
all right the beautiful on the slide
there it is jules with the first block
on the slide and now ak
one hit away jules goes for the safer
option down four again now he's showing
some signs of light
this is what he needs to do right at
least get one round on the board
that way even if you lose the game just
like a little bit of like hope in your
mind
aka now though just with the ankle
checks
preventing jewels from moving
beautiful how does he do it right again
it's the timing man this kid's got
different timing goes for the full combo
jules lower than half health 35 seconds
left tries to go for a little poke but
he's got to get more than that but ak
again with the launcher
yeah he had the side step two right
there or decides them into the downfall
or two and a lot of times the downfall
twos that ak has they're they come out
of the frustration he's putting into the
players right like you saw there a bunch
of just the generic downforce just to
frustrate the opponent and then when the
force frustrates like dude i'm tired
like every time he comes in and gets a
little poke and it's just the first
grace thing he's not even doing that
much damage right he's only lost like
maybe 10 15
but then they get impatient they rush in
and the nick is like i'm just gonna do a
safe downpour too you know it's got a
good hitbox out there you trying to run
into anything here my timing on this as
a keep out tool is going to prevent you
from getting in on it and so it's just
really threatening the opponent into
being too offensive
and it's always paid off he's very very
good at the strategy
yeah and also another another fact about
jules is that jules has been around with
ak and dojin even before the proceeds
and so this these guys have been playing
even
before they became legit
uh is what i'm saying that's awesome
you know that these guys and girls have
grown with each other they know each
other so well and i think that's
beautiful you know
it really is no of course anytime you
have people that you've trained with
your whole life uh to finally like you
know sometimes you'll see some players
excel earlier than others right so
finally to see like your other friends
kind of you know catch up to that level
and like meet you in the winner's final
of a tekken online challenge you know
that's amazing right so shout outs to
both these guys but right now you know
only one of them can win the tournament
uh we're gonna see who's gonna get into
that grand finals a case ahead one to
zero this is a race to three best of
five in this situation uh we're going to
dwell more to syria for game two and
jewel sticking it out with jim kazama
yeah here we are at the one with the
city this has been jules's go-to pick
also recently from
geometric plane
to uh normal d cereal a lot of uh
interesting choices here for jules
damn he triple pumped that slide very
nice
made him think about it a few times
god wow look at that he blocked him and
then he fade punished with the standing
f4 wow okay aka that was really
now it has the momentum here we go down
four first one
breaks the throat
one check
oh my gosh
that was it was so risky to even try to
attack once ak did the empty jump uh
regardless jules swung in it worked out
because it could try to look like a
delay hopkins afterwards
uh but jules on the board here
very common calculated both of these
players down three folks coming for ak
jules gets hit gets clipped by the
orbital heel and this should close it
out ak takes it one round a piece
[Music]
and that was a crazy round that orbital
from ak is deadly man
he makes people check their ankles so
often that everyone wants to duck
against them and that's a better option
you know throw out the hop kick you know
let him punish you but at least he's not
doing these lows to you anymore
dude
that's the way to step too right
of course yeah decide that right there
and you know that that's one of jin's
weaker side you got to be careful some
of this up there but
the downforce are paying off and you
know jules not an electric happy
chin player right like you're not seeing
any electric wind hook fists or any kind
of like 50 coming out of the four fours
are here and those ones you can size
them right
yeah oh magic four connects ak catches
him with a counter hit and now jules is
in big trouble has to make the right
guess here
what the hell is the catch of movement
look at again again the side step right
down forward two it's there every time
for wall carries good
damage shut the damage
that is an unfortunate situation to be
in for jules and ak makes the right
choices over and over again now he's up
two games and jules has none so far this
is a lot of momentum for ak rip
it's a problem for sure uh you know
jules has other characters right like
it's not just this gin uh
i think the bob might be a better choice
here
you know what i don't even think i don't
even know what the right choice is at
this point i i just love seeing these
guys go at it with their names and
playing at the highest level of tekken
possible as possible as they can this is
just amazing to me this is actually just
you know good ass tekken for me
right now i mean the the problem is
obviously sidestep downpour twos right
like 8k is catching them the time and
time again
and of course you know aka he likes to
set the tone of the match immediately
right he comes out there he breaks your
ankle a few times or he comes out there
he'll slide a few times and just to get
you made just to make you think about it
because everyone knows ak's playstyle
you know that no makes a mix-up strategy
so they're all scared of it right as
soon as one of them hits so he doesn't
have to do a bunch of them to implant
that thought into your mind
uh but of course after that you know
he's playing this different game plan
but you're still thinking about the
other strategy and sure enough here out
comes the bob uh so yeah i'm i'm kind of
happy to see the switch here to be
honest i don't think the gin was working
uh right i like like i said he doesn't
really use a lot of the tools of gin uh
probably because of the way aka stepping
him and he probably has some history
there where he's familiar with it right
but bob here definitely a little bit
more underrepresented i'd love to see
how this goes
yeah okay let's see now different
strategies have come into play now that
jules has pulled out the bob but ak will
remain ak will remain the same way he's
playing so let's see how things are
going to go here 15 seconds have been
spent these guys finally gets the duck
in on the 4-1 jewels gonna carry to the
wall no just a bit short
smart stuff and look at this dominant
first round from jules here just ducking
that one high for one string getting the
full launch in that uh was really the
turning point solid first round for
jules here again
jules again so on point with the way
that he's playing right now ak's in for
a lot of hurt this is also so good okay
for jules aka half health goes for the
bet but no gets punished by jules
i love to check the daffodil one there
solid defense too from jules right now
gotta maintain this life lead don't give
him a chance to down forward to you oh
my goodness
the risks are coming out and aka finds
the rage drive
okay the patience
aka
paying off so well now what we call
jules here in the philippines he's is
that he's the iron wall defense simply
because of how good he is when it comes
to certain situations he blocks
everything it's so good and ak's
exploiting the weakness the flaws of
that
that's crazy
and ak was just so patient there right
like he was behind incredibly behind the
walton two one caught him early in the
round again but despite being so behind
he stayed composed the entire time never
felt like he was behind
but here we go jules again building an
earth another early life lead three
rounds in a row
goes for the okie combo aka half health
goes for the slide in goes for another
will he go for more that is the question
jules right now trying to look for more
openings 20 seconds left ak outside of
race jules has to close this one up
without giving ak rage
just hell sleeping bro oh it'll work
good
oh god
i don't get the hell sweep up
the race drive from ak he's not dead but
time runs out
and ak gets another round back from
behind again
we all knew he's coming but somehow we
all got hit by that too
aka playing so well right now he is on
his way through three only jewels in
this set ladies and gentlemen we're
going to see the wall here the king
charged he charges
just gets the steel pedal in good
punished by jewels
yeah ak you know he's looking to be
sidestep there it is that time the
counter hit down for two and he used
that dapper too when aka did decide to
write because you know the downpour two
is coming out from aka that would set
point and that will be that ak
three to zero over duels moves on to the
grand finals on the winner's side of
things aka looking impressive here very
impressive
we're already on you're shocked the fact
that
yeah right we're already aware of the
fact that aka is a good player in fact
he's a great player
but every time he wins like this we're
still so amazed how can he pull it off
it's it's the beauty of high level
tekken i i love it i love it
yeah and and honestly it's it's the
mental game for ak right like the actual
tekken game it's not even as important
to the mental game he's playing with his
opponent because he breaks his
opponent's defense early and then
they're thinking about that the rest of
the set and that like that hopkins or
the always the orbit i think orbital at
the final round there and that's because
of the